هنا جثه احد الشهداء الذين تم
انتشالهم قبل
قليل
من داخل المنزل الذي تعرض للقصف في الليله
الماضيه وتحديد في هذا المربع السكني
والذي يضم عده منازل وروضه اي رياض اطفال
تاوي
[موسيقى]
نازحين اللي صار انه ننا نيام يعني الساعه
11 ونص تقريبا هيك فسمعنا دبه انا ما يعني
سمعتها وقع علي الجدار وقع البنات وولعت
الدار وبقينا تحت الانقاد فجوا شباب
الحاره وطلعوه من تحت الانقاد وطلعوا
بناتي من تحت اطفال مستش فيين طفلين اي
بنات اثنتين نور وملكه سجود يعني هذا
استهداف مش للمنزل واحد هو لمربع سكنر اثر
من منزل انت انت ملاحظ يعني هي منزل هي
منزلين يعني هذا كان مقصف القديم لكن هي
منزل هي منزلين هي ثلاثه هي اربعه لانه حي
مربع بكامل كم شهيد كم شهيد في عندك اربعه
مراه واولادها
وحماتها والشاب اللي احنا مش عارفين منه
مقطوع راسه اللي احنا اخذناه من غير حتى
اه واللي بنات الثنتين بنات الثنتين في
شهداء اسفل
الوجين
مشط السطح فاب على السطح نطلع طلعنا الحجه
لكن ض الاطفال الاثنين وامهم والحمد لله
طلعنا البنتين احنا نيحهم والشاب اللي
قلنا لك احنا لقينا الجسد من غير راس لحتى
الان ما شفنا راسه ولا عرفنا مين
هو